Kylie Jenner reveals she's getting lip
fillers again I'm obsessed with it the
21 year old Keeping Up with the
Kardashians star and Kylie cosmetics
founder took to her Instagram stories to
thank Ponte cosmetic dermatology of
Beverly Hills quote for coming through
late last night with a lip touch-up
yep that's Kylie with significantly
fuller lips posing it up in a white robe
Ponte replied to Kylie on Instagram
writing it was my pleasure seeing you
again your lips look amazing on that
gorgeous face of yours the move came as
a surprise to many of Kylie's fans the
reason just three months ago after a fan
commented on this Instagram photo that
she looked like the old Kylie the
reality star replied I got rid of all my
filler Kylie first confessed to getting
lip fillers in 2015 on Keeping Up amid
speculation she'd had work done I have
temporary lip fillers it's just an
insecurity of mine and it's what I
wanted to do I want to admit to the lips
but people are so quick to judge me on
everything so I might have tiptoed
around the truth but I didn't fly and
last year Kylie revealed why she got
injections during an episode of her
spin-off show life of Kylie I was 15 and
I was insecure about my lips I had
really small lips and it was like one of
my first kisses and a guy he was like I
didn't think you were gonna be a good
kisser because you have such small lips
but I took that really hard just when a
guy you like says that I don't know it
just really affected me I just didn't
feel like desirable or pretty I really
wanted bigger lips I would just like
over line my lips with lip liner just to
create the illusion of bigger lips and
then finally I was like this lip liner
is
it ended up getting my lips done during
a Twitter Q&A in July Kylie said her
daughter stormy looked like her twin
with one exception quote the one thing I
was insecure about she has she has the
most perfect lips in the whole entire
world she didn't get those from me
Kylie recently took to social media
again to answer her fans burning
questions including her plans to have
more babies I want another baby but when
is the question and I'm definitely not
ready right this second and I don't know
when I will be have I thought of baby
names for my next baby I have but I'm
haven't found anything that I love but I
definitely want another girl hopefully
and I want her to have a really feminine
name that's all I know
et caught up with Kylie's mom Kris
Jenner and sister Kendall in July and
they dished on the ever-growing
Kardashian family I mean it's so much
fun the family grows and it's getting
bigger all the time and yeah it's really
fun to see the babies have babies